bonjour tout le monde
c'est
pour nous
non sans déconner d'alice exclusive
et on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
nouvelle vidéo commentée voir en
finale
donc pour cent alors là me direz-vous
à ce stade-là de la vidéo mais
pourquoi était-il impliqué auprès
commenté sur 24 alors qu'ida dit que je
l'étais pour lui humecter tout
simplement
parce que pour ça je ne suivrai pas
fait je suis quelqu'un qui se lassent
ultra rapidement
bg c'est pourquoi donc imaginer sa
marraine aperçu de côté
et puis là je me suis dit pourquoi ne
pas
pourquoi jouer tv c'est d'apprécier le
jeu les agents tentent d'amorcer je
voulais à m'entraîner à un collègue
m'a piqué mon petit prix
en gros le monde
dites-vous que voir une portée par la
vidéo à un seuil critique qui est fait
sur la personne âgée détendez-vous et
avec cette vidéo de l'événement dans
votre tête avec ça
ou pourquoi les monades
houcine pour les alcoolos enfin bref
donc c'est parti donc c'est en
démolition sur l'amas de jeunes c'est
plus long
parce que je ne citerai pas le nom de
madoff
backup serait donc c'est parti pour
cette partie est une bonne partie dans
le sens
outre c'est vraiment jouer stratégie
voyez donc lâché ses couleurs pour
cent pas
pour ma part ça complètement foiré
pour le moment les évacue tout au long
de la partie je m'habitue au cours de la
deuxième décennie
donc là je me souviens que ça reçu
par l'afp agence de cet excellent
technicien nantais au peuple sang
% en fait moins que je vais tout de
suite que la passation de surdité
je trouve que c'est plus difficile
d'accès selon moi
la robe j'entends quelqu'un qui avance
me retourne je vais tuer
je voudrais pas que je sois à fond dans
mon cas ce cas c'est vraiment un chien
on entend le mot but but but donc c'est
tout de suite repérables
et donc plus que prévu et les factures
donc c'était lui parme
un peu déçu si je vois même pas
stable
enfin à quel point notre prière je
suis c'est monstrueux si votre sac à 47
a su être très très très joli
moi je disais donc ma classe c'est pour
ça qu'à 47% le ca du t4 dans le gard
légale pour les blocs l'afp avec la
tour grands chargeurs
axelle 47 et si les grands chargeurs par
chargeurs boîte %
après des études secondaires elle
mange
rc genk adressé
en forme après avoir vu sa surprise de
voir son gagne-pain elle montre que la
france et 38 dossiers saisis donc ma
place à quelqu'un en sait plus
distinguer
j'exagère améliorer comme à tous j'ai
pris qu'un équipement plutôt j'ai pris
pour cet expert ex ante
t cruel
un restaurant mais là je souhaite pas
surfer sur le web studio
le gérant du mal à vous retrouvez donc
l algérie un peu plus tôt devant mon
ordi ces faits à base de terres rares a
offert un petit retour en arrière on va
chercher les serveurs
oui dix capsules sur le coude la vie
donc je disais donc e que matoub
marathon
% jc puis
dans un tweet
bourgi sécu
qui est un marathon et le dge c'est plus
à faire ça c'est sûr
donc donc la mangeoire attaquer donc
j'ai plutôt vu en fait cela a vraiment
envie attaques sur arnaud inclus
parce que si vous laissez pas jouer
l'objectif est donc je commence par
l'ansés gaspiller les grands maîtres
comme ça gratuitement c'est vraiment
triste pour ma part
%
donc finalement voilà je vais plutôt
aller sur paris
sachant que des plus difficiles d'accès
comme dit tout à l'heure par cela
de plus il a fait son commando du
circuit hama centre sans trop de
difficultés dans l'euphorie
là-bas ils sont deux
j'arrive à avoir les deux beaucoup ne
pourra pas reporter les parents roger
lemerre
e parce que tout simplement ce match il
est donc on voit pas mais en fait pour
cent du projet vedette
sur le tarmac revoilà donc là j'ai mis
en place leurs spots
donc je comprends fois la dernière en
barrage mais les scousers faire enfin
bref
donc la technique va vraiment être en
championnat je leur dis qu'ils foutent
de nous prendre bac
un ou deux buts ou pas être
2 des sites débuté via les libéraux
chère au nucléaire
% sachant que la f rance pour un appât
je veux que les gars et je ne sais pas
ce qui se dit dans une vidéo qu'il
était vraiment une grosse pub tête
% photo police traite égyptien
et en parlant de [ __ ] % mathilde
d'espèces de pour françoise à sortir
la semaine écoutez plutôt
si ces transferts entre clubs bien
encore croire à la ramasse des gens
qui partent à la chasse au trésor
c'est pas croyable
il court partout sur la map les
attendent que vous le pouvez quelqu'un
mince poli un petit voyou polémique sur
la main puis il court il court il court
il court il court
alors que la colère divine qui l'a
chargé de la ville les marques en fait
vous avez pas voir où je l'avais mais
pour cent dans l'âme radars étaient
brouillés et donc j'ai mis un peu près
sur la page du sundgau et j'aurais dû
la mettre sur pied
c'est la rentrée pour ma part en plus
des futures de personnes froissart monde
les personnes par jour
mais j'ai eu très très chaud mais j'ai
quand même réussi à avoir
cet accueil car on sait qu'il a trouvé
comme on dit un peu parce qu'elle a pas
trop de recul pour s'en aller à ses
frais six pièces et plus tôt
voilà toutes les qualités pour une
bonne arme je trouve
dans le cas où je suis je suis pas en
attaque c'est vraiment pas beaucoup
joué les objectifs jd ciné
les amis faire escale à marseille
après la défaite allah
on va faire la manche
donc lui un gros stress l'avenir kifaya
je continue mon chemin vers le milieu de
la matinée à trouver un emploi parce
qu'en principe être là-bas il passe au
mieux
donc j'aime qu'un peu regardez là-bas
jeudi j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé jouer
la stratégie de la fed partis flamands
un pur bonheur d'habitude je je vais un
peu n'importe quoi et si la chance se
réveille
ainsi encore eu lieu
le fameux avec 547 au revoir
donc faire l'achat par la russie de la
mort à hama tarder
m la fois défende pas uniquement pour
jouer sur des formes avancées en amont
très stupide de ma part
%
donc la forteresse intrus stratégie que
je le fasse parce que c'est beau ça
pète
j'ai complètement loupé complètement
loupé
la marque volkswagen a fait état de
palestine pour cela aussi que j'aime
beaucoup je suis toujours facile je suis
très actif comme ça
enfin bref c'est la dernière des dvd et
des fusées nucléaire
pour san rafael de 3 me fait beaucoup
penser à 27 ans auteur du tube de
renfort de très beaux ces quatre
courses de la fin 3
mais air france m'a fait vraiment penser
à 7% à cette arme-là de modern
warfare 2 que j'aime beaucoup et si
jamais je refais une vidéo commentée
sur mac os pour tablettes peuvent être
déduits de la fête des jeunes qu'on
fait une sorte de roulement
et bah écoutez je vous montrerai quoi
il montre au second set sa maison
pierre belloche partout
un vote ont gagné ou pas je vous laisse
la surprise donc là c'est en défense
et c'est vraiment là que je vais et je
trouve vraiment bien joué ici
donc là encore une fois faut que je
retrouve le bon joueur
pilier de civisme
c'est moi qui joue quoi surprendre mais
je le redis
l'ajout au début j celui trouvé très
vite du multi contre comme ça
pourquoi
dans le jeu est beaucoup plus
j'ai vraiment très envie d'écrire
l'une des plus belles forêts s'est
amélioré par les blagues
de petits voulez
c'est vraiment parler stratégie donc
tout avoir pour conséquence avec des
collines des péquistes égal avec le
plus vite possible au début la marque
polémique
c'est incroyable que l'on s'est fait
prendre le ballon satin
impressions je m'en sors plutôt bien et
tracter une sorte bien
donc là je sens que je vais passer ma
part pas comme d'habitude c'est défend
pas
la technique réside dans le bac à
penser ça me faut vous faussez d'eads
en 2008 et des prendre part le dos
effectivement très respectée
donc s'ils ont acquis le deuxième je
n'ai pas eu je crois qu'on aurait pu
pour recharger
pas vraiment je conseille ça pour être
à ta ma vidéo dresse sur le tutorat
des facteurs là j'ai posté aujourd'hui
tout à l'heure
si nécessaire je crois qu'ils sont en
vie ou plus
si c'est vraiment ça fait très plaisir
cette misère c'est vraiment génial
et je vous invite à aller la voir si
vous voulez vraiment mettre les choses
au clair entre les flashcodes les coûts
structurels
si vous voulez apprendre un peu comment
les faire compliqué j'entendais les
balles de set et revoilà je pense qu'il
me manquait une balle pour la voir
il a préféré assurer son coût lié
au couteau
paralysée j'ai stoppé
terra membres
j'entends quelqu'un qui amorce elle a
même eu en regardant je l'entendais je
ne sais pas pourquoi je ne suis pas
retournée d'été ils ont acquis une
très bonne stratégie
les corinthians posées à notre allié
à la finale de la coupe c'est comme
quand je m'attendais vraiment passé
à la rentrée
% comme je connais vraiment mal et
maintenant vous allez voir que l'on va
alors je me suis fait unique film
dérivé vers détroit et demi et je me
suis pris à froid
entraîné par la chute des prix à la
consommation ont baissé plus que par le
passé quand quelqu'un
à voir paris ap toujours un petit malin
pour venir souper préparé leur coup
donc là ils étaient tous âges légaux
rosemont bien stoppées
pour cent et ce lors des phases seront
même qu'elle se fait remarquer en voir
par où il y arrive
c'est vraiment très intime
la route lance m
cet enfant
chamaa sébastien viseur laser très
bizarre takashi par noureddine espèces
d'arbres de doubler les gamins de
servisair
donc là en principe les petits malins
que les autres et s'exiler à faire
péter hart il faut passer par là
logiquement regarde-moi darlas
devrait passer par la migros défaut
dans tous les clubs ici c'est de ne
jamais presse presque jamais regardez
nos radars jugement des autres
administrations c'est affreux
or et argent du mandat lors du sommet du
g20 le savoir
donc si c'est pour aller de d'espèces
déjà sortirait pourtant la semaine
dans la semaine
si j'avais eu l'idée d'inviter deux
amis pour la faire dormir chez moi le
soir mon sens en foot c'est ma vie pour
biarritz non je suis méchante
mais pour cent en finale je pense pas
que ce soit possible de le faire tout
seul et de la gela frais vers minuit
pour que
j'ai encore plus peur d'être daté de
demain sur les petits sur le dos
mitchell
donc là je regarde plus
ils veulent pas nous prendre part à
notre côté là où dans ses objectifs
a cassé tout ce que je sais c'est très
possible en principe les gens aiment
bien faire ça
la part des états fédérés dans la
partie quand même
là je me suis plutôt bien sortir
vraiment je suis surpris
je suis très surpris car dans cette
partie il n'y avait pas de lancer un
coup de pub les gens étaient vraiment
c'était vraiment cool ne sortait pas
des armes de nouveaux liens franchement
les gens étaient tous
c'était assez agréable que je dois
bien dire j'ai pris un certain plaisir
à jouer dans cette partie
car à la pause mans l'a vraiment mon
ami m'a très très bien comme ariane
qui a soutenu et ça fait très plaisir
sans rien
le deuxième article apporte quoi
la scène textile balancer harrachis pas
pourquoi je ne sais pas moi toute seule
écoutez pourquoi j'étais tout le temps
au lendemain de la fin 8e
ça allait vraiment sur le devant le
stade de l'aube
devant
s'il allait vraiment sur le devant de sa
kippa soldats
la fa cup
excusez-moi si ce soit face à la fin
seulement c'est vraiment pas de la fota
va maintenant sur les faits
excusez-moi si je parle très vite comme
ça mais c'est
pas de ma faute parce que c'est de ma
faute
mais en soi c'est pas ma faute parce que
c'est une habitude que j'ai pris
qui a entraîné la mort jafar renvoi
débarrassé de ses transactions
je remercie
monique herment et les autres
neuf clubs de l'élite
la forêt privée
je remercie tous prix
toutes ces heures difficiles je pense
pas
pour moi c'est vraiment super de la part
de fonds propres mais ça fait vraiment
très plaisir d'écouter en moins de six
jours j'ai gagné près de
le coût de 39 d'abonnés
société
39e
ah ça fait vraiment vraiment vraiment
très plaisir ma vidéo spéciale de son
abonné n'a pas été beaucoup plus
sûrement parce que les gens dans la
marde de deux coups de gueule de youtube
ils s'amusent pas taper
vidéo le turbo boost aux yeux bleus
forts de leur savoir-faire
les drs pour passer de petits
aaah il était en train de le conquérir
plus important
la charmante et qu'elle fait partie des
42 pts
donc là je vais vous parler
je crois je crois que c'est ça qui va
se passer je vais sortir dans ces cas
voilà je me retournais là
surprise à la plage le sifflet facile
ça c'est vraiment dommage pour moi j
sur l'amendé et je regarde mon cher
mais seulement l afp affreux
en effet le savoir par je ne sais quel
miracle
les femmes on voit la première manche
si vous avez décidé
tottenham et vidéo des critiques des
conseils
respectives des faits et du tout cela
renvoyait tout toutefois la baisse qui
sera dans la description j'ai exclusif @
mais ils pourraient faire un effort
% vous savez maestra depuis que je fais
vraiment servir des vidéos stadiers un
peu près depuis
le coup
trois barges 3-2 trois marocains moyens
oui un mois et demi et j'ai déjà 230
aux abonnés
je trouve ça vraiment mai
extraordinaire racheter si un jour
j'arrive au village vous ferez des 10%
il a en revanche pas réglé à la
démarche peu assurée comme coupe-faim
là or j'avais un mandat d'arrêt est
passé de côté du but je regarde à
gauche at-il encore rappelé
j'ai beaucoup lu le public
d'ailleurs être arrivé à un peu la
jellaba
ensuite vous allez voir à nouveau
arriver je vais avoir beaucoup de le cio
savage plainte s'appuie sur un plan de
match trop tard m
pas assez prendre la tangente
hortefeux
j'ai réussi à se développer j'aime
vraiment et là je vais maintenant
pouvoir malheureusement fait leur temps
je suis content
lafarge était lancée là je ne pouvais
plus m'arrêter là vraiment
et la mrh ne pas comprendre pourquoi mes
objectifs proforma ça regardez
pourquoi je me disais les premiers comme
ça parce qu'il avait été expulsé
ce débat-là l'isie
pour écouter les experts ces vidéos à
l'appui
un double cliquer sur j'aime ça dure
vraiment plaisir c'est à quel point
abonnez-vous et c'est encore mieux ça
fait vraiment plaisir si vous voulez
vous aussi
en fait
les décideurs de l'ue
l'attaquant chasse comme ça
pour les abonnés à faro
on veut pas un plan b pour se la péter
mais c'est vraiment parce que ses dires
des gens nous soutiennent c'est ça qui
fait
personne ou presque tous abattus à sion
aussi que j'adore les jeux et que j'aime
bien de vous présenter
dangereux
et puis voilà donc on se quitte sur ce
magnifique essai
tu sais pas ce que je fais
enfin bon bois lacté salut tout le
monde je n'attire sont dans un instant
je vous remercie d'avoir vu la vidéo
commenté
les pays qui soutiennent
abonnez-vous
et voilà tchao tout le monde bye merci
encore
la séance de lundi
football
désir
suite
c'est bon